what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba Here I am back talking about Game
of Thrones and I want to give a quick
pension this is not a paid promotional
shout-out I just wanted to say that I
use the TV time app a lot and if you
guys ever want to keep up to date with
other shows I'm watching or if I happen
to miss putting up a review for Game of
Thrones you can go to the TV time app
it's for free do the cost you any money
so just follow me there it's just an
awesome app I love using it I didn't
review episode 2 and 3 because I watched
them a little late and if you're more
than a day late a lot of people don't
care anymore but I watched this one on
time so I'm here to talk about it
episode 4 of season 7 the spoils of war
episode 3 & 4 were awesome and this one
day I was planning on just reviewing the
season premiere episode and then the
season finale episode but this season
just keeps on delivering the goods man
the rewards my friend easily the most
rewarding season we've had and I'm a
sucker for reward driven stories like
let's build up the MCU and give fans the
Avengers let's have Frodo and the rest
of the Fellowship's suffer for two
movies then give them a hell of a bunch
of rewards and Return of the King and
that's what this season is beginning and
that's what this season is feeling like
in terms of just giving the audience
what they want if might not always be
good for the characters were rooting for
but it's certainly delivering the
thrills I'm not gonna go over every
single scene or dialogue spoken in this
episode just the bits that stood out to
me but there's quite a few so early in
the episode Mira she decides to leave
Winterfell she has this very
impassionate goodbye from bran now that
bran is the three-eyed Raven he's kind
of the three-eyed dick at the same time
one point he says I'm not bran not
anymore even though he was rather close
hearted to Mira in that very specific
moment it made me go I really do love
what they've done with bran cuz I'll be
honest didn't really love bran for the
first few seasons didn't really care for
her storyline but seeing who he's turned
into now I feel like the actor is doing
a really good job with the role and it
just makes bran a much more mysterious a
compelling character overall and I felt
like it was the scenes here that you
really got to see that as he gets to
scenes in this episode one is a goodbye
and one and another one as a reunion and
both he's out that ammo
all about them and it just keeps making
me wonder how much are his feelings
truly indifferent to those that he
really did love and care about prior to
this change he's had he doesn't really
care to give me runs a lot of praise and
his mirror girls she's not a lot she's
not a lover brand she would have sucked
his crippled dick if he had uh I should
I keep that at me I'll get at me and for
a guy who's a fan of the character of
Mira it was kind of a bummer the way she
just left like there was no fan service
given to that moment see I'm not sure
she'd be coming back I wouldn't be
surprised if she is coming back in fact
I'm hoping she is cuz that's that'd be a
bummer if that is her last episode in
the show it was flat-out heartbreaking
to see the way Mira was responding to
how bran wasn't giving her the love and
gratitude that she truly deserved after
everything she's done for the guy so in
terms of brand it really does make me go
how much a brand is actually left in
there are we ever gonna see this guy get
emotional again there's this great scene
where Arya and Sansa reunite and when
they reunite that feeling just kept
kicking in that feeling that goes wow
these two have no idea how much they've
changed they just have no clue and even
though they both changes individuals you
can see that in the actors faces they
provided moments in that scene where
they will see the younger versions of
themselves they haven't seen each other
in years and in that moment you see
these characters who have changed so
much start to go back to that childhood
sibling rivalry yet loving type of vibe
and I love that exchange of dialogue
when they were looking at the statue of
their father how arias pointing out the
statue looks nothing like Ned which I
thought is just a really cool detail to
have inside of this game of Thrones
world like yeah make sense the people
who like sculpted this together probably
didn't have a perfect idea what his face
looked like and Sansa says everyone who
knew his face is dead
Arya looks at her sister and says we're
not Oh little does she know that bran
still alive it's just so rewarding to
see hope and faith being instilled in
the Starks it's a it's it's a great
positive reward for the audience so side
note I really like the writing when Arya
tells song said that she has a kill list
that Joffrey was at the top of that list
but Sansa kind of just laughs it off and
I really believe in Ariane it it's like
why would my sister have something like
this
I know you are but in another compelling
reunion moment when Aria gets the
reunited would brand brackets the show
Aria and confirmed for Sansa that he is
who he says he is when he's telling Aria
that he thought she'd be going to King's
Landing because Cersei is on her list so
you can just see that look on Santa's
face like truth and she knows already
hasn't talked to Brad yet so for her to
now see that brand knows about the list
without being told about it bran really
does have these visionary powers it's
just such a compelling and rewarding
reunion for the Starks so many of the
Starks have died but the remaining
children are all reuniting and they've
all changed physically yes but
emotionally especially and I just
remember in the earlier seasons I didn't
really give a [ __ ] about these kids
specifically brand Sansa and Arya and I
remember early on a lot of people really
the sort of loving Arya and I I just
wasn't but I've grown and really love
them and Arya has grown to be easily one
of my favorite characters on the show
then Jon Snow it takes Daenerys to see
the cave of dragonglass and Jon Snow
this dude's hit El Dorado if I could
find a cave like that full of weed yeah
baby
so Jon takes the nurse to the cave and
he shows her writing from the children
of the forest you know the first men and
how the first spent band together to
fight the White Walkers and Daenerys you
can see is really starting to believe
John about these white mother Walkers
get it and Jon really needs the nurse to
fight with him Daenerys is insistent
that she'll only do it if Jon bends the
knee and I love that conflict cuz John
has his reasonings not to bow you know
the people in the north won't like it he
knows about the Mad King but we know as
an audience that Daenerys is so much
more than that it's so much different
than the Mad King but Johnny doesn't
really know Daenerys too well yet so he
can't just make that decision but you
can see that John it's kind of siik it's
sort of believed that she's very much
when I'm different than the Mad King I
think in the end Daenerys will prove
herself to John and end up bowing the
knee right now totally get that he's not
a completely understand deer take your
time but I think down the road he will
and now we haven't been getting a hell
of a lot of Tyrion in this season yet
but there is that scene when Tyrion
gives word to Daenerys about what
happened at Casterly Rock how they're
losing their allies and there's a line
there I don't remember it word for word
but basically Daenerys is questioning
Tyrion on whether or not he's giving the
best of plans or is he holding back as
he doesn't really want
the Lannister army because you know
Tyrians a Lannister it's not something I
actually question or thought might be in
the back of Tyrians mind but the look
ontarians face and what happens later in
the episode it does show there is some
conflict there like I said it wasn't
something I was expecting the show to
actually delve into but it only makes
sense to explore it at least a little
bit of course you'd be affected by this
Tyrion is not a ruthless cold-blooded
killer like his sisters this dude has a
heart and at the end of the day there's
a lot of people more than just Cersei
who were gonna die and it also puts his
brother Jaime in harm's way but in that
same scene you see Daenerys turns to get
men she gets all mad Queen about that
[ __ ] blood sorry to boil she's talking
about just riding into the Red Keep and
just storming the castle and taking back
what's hers is killing everyone in the
words of wisdom that Jon Snow gives her
I love that a Daenerys asked John for
advice he gives these great words of
wisdom about her she just stormed the
Red Keep and started killing everyone a
lot of innocent people would die and the
image that has caused so many people to
follow in her footsteps would just be
completely ruined and she'd be turning
into something that she's setting out to
be the exact opposite Oh so yeah that
scene was great because we're gonna see
the support and Ally that Jon Snow is
becoming and we also get to see a hint
of Daenerys you know becoming mad with
power
decide which Jon Snow is reluctant on
only anymore feel as to why he probably
hasn't bowed the knee just yet guys how
grand was that scene when Brandon Arya
or fighting each other Ari was held
captive by the hand for so long she
couldn't defeat it so in this moment she
takes the opportunity to train with
Brienne who's the one that defeated the
hammer it was so cool because they're
pretty much equally matched in terms of
fighting skills in some way Arya is a
little bit she still has the Arya style
which she began developing in season one
now she has more martial arts tricks up
her sleeve it's cool to see their
different fighting styles mesh with each
other I love when fight scenes do that
where you have one very specific fighter
and another very specific fighter going
toe-to-toe Arya a little more fancy
Brienne more ruthless and they're
fighting each other yet you know they're
equally matched the entire time and I
totally believe it Arya in that scene it
was super badass this is a really badass
and it does get me excited for the
chemistry that Arya and Brienne will
have in the show and when Sansa was
watching she I thought that she was
probably jealous of Arya in that moment
you know they didn't make it pitch
perfect clear this isn't the Dark Tower
that's just what I gathered I mean
Santa's been a
used and tortured for so long she
suffered her way to the position she now
holds an aria yes she suffered a lot in
her own ways very different ways though
and it's allowed her to become this
badass warrior with these skills that
Sansa simply doesn't have I totally get
it if they're jealous I'm jealous of my
brother have you seen the views on his
channel compared to mine jealousy okay
let's talk about that battle scene that
battle scene
I know some people do Game of Thrones
reactions and for this channel which
features plenty of those I've definitely
had requests to do that I've done them
because the show is really an hour long
and I feel like usually when I watch a
game of Thrones episodes I'm usually
just kind of quiet and still when I
watch an episode and I'm already on a
fan if I end up having not that much of
a reaction in a short video I can only
imagine what will be like for an hour
but this season just their episodes have
so many scenes where I'm just alone in
my living room I'm being super vocal
though what the hell is going on on
screen and it seems like this battle
they get you tell her only on Episode
four bran is now teamed up with Gene
they're waging the war against the Narus
and right now the Lannister army they're
just camping out prepping for their next
battle resting up all that crap and they
hear a stampede of horses approaching
them from the other side of the hill the
Lannister army prepares for battle and
it's wonderfully shot it's beautifully
shot cuz it's just a spectacular way of
build-up where they're looking at like
the horizon of the hilltop they just
hear it it just keeps getting louder and
louder but they don't see an army yet
then suddenly it's a Dothraki man the
Dothraki are riding toward them which
was freaking sweet badass entrance for
sure like to me the dothraki already
have a pretty good chance of winning
then of the Dothraki but you know
Jamie's a good commander they can
probably at least survive this maybe not
win buddy
I wasn't thinking like Jamie could die
or something but then with amazing HBO
special effects Daenerys and rogue on
the good side Daenerys and rogue on drog
on drogon will go I'm drogon come riding
in and they [ __ ] that [ __ ] up like
Dothraki already scary enough for the
Lannisters but a direct they had no
chance no chance man the Dothraki
they're slaughtering the Lannister army
drogon is torching soldiers and wiping
out supplies and weapons left and right
it is a NASA
her oh my god was it awesome there were
just some like that one shot drug on
just comes flying any torches like a
perfect line from the Lannister army
perspective this is nothing short of
horrifying people are being burnt alive
left and right it's pure chaos it's it's
chaos and Jamie dude is just losing more
and more hope as it continues it was
strangely conflicting cuz yeah do I want
to nervous to win of course I do of
course I want Daenerys to win but I love
Jamie and I love Bronn I got a special
soft spot for bran and because I love
those characters
I wasn't feeling bad for the army but I
was feeling really bad for Jaime and
Bronn cuz they're just getting
demolished out there they literally have
no fighting chance and actually win it
even went bran gets to that giant you
know crossbow which mechanism thing I
don't know the name of it taking me
years to remember certain characters
names from the show that's called it was
intense because I'm like oh my god I'm
gonna kill a dragon I'm gonna kill a
dragon oh really kill the dragon species
certainly do that what's gonna go wrong
it's cool cuz the giant crossbow thing
it Pierce's drug on but it doesn't kill
him but it's still an effective moment
because shows Daenerys in that moment
and for anyone who survived from the
Lannister side that those dragons are
not invincible
you can still harm them and they could
probably be taken down knowing the way
the show works it puts the nurse in a
position where she has to listen to
Tyrion she has to remain strategic she
can't just go in there riding into
battle all the time it's exactly what
Tyrion was fearing about the situation
this role Daenerys now seriously might
have more of these being built right now
her has plenty of these built right now
and when Jaime who's lost all hopes he's
one chance he hasn't possibly killing
Daenerys he goes for it what an intense
scene because prior to that Tyrion you
see he's at the battle and he's just
watching everyone gets slaughtered and
you could see he has sympathy for all
the Lannister people that are being just
burnt alive they're just dying and when
Jamie's riding afternoon Aerys he just
starts muttering yeah you [ __ ] idiot
what a conflicting seen it's like
conflicting for Tyrion because he's
fighting for Daenerys but he doesn't
want his brother Jaime to die
I don't want Jaime and I as an audience
member I don't want the nares to die he
just yeah it's the first time in these
series these two characters have ever
come so close to each other they made
eye contact and before he can get too
drunk on
fire breeds nose and brawn matches to
sweep in tackle Jamie off the horse and
into the water
good save brawn good say so yeah that
battle was absolutely superb
yes visually looks fantastic and because
there's been so many action sequences so
early in the season he keeps making me
wonder what their final battle is gonna
be like cuz battle of the bastards was
the best battle sequence they've had
thus far and every season has at least
one major battle sequence that tops last
season and with all the crazy [ __ ]
they've been doing so early in this show
I'm only wondering what the big final
battle of this season's gonna be the
reason the battles are greater because
it never loses sight of what makes this
show so work which is the emotional
capacity and the emotional impact of the
characters cuz even in this battle
sequence it lets you take the time to
see the journey of what's going on with
the main characters in this battle you
see Tyrians conflict you can see
Daenerys is like soaking up the power or
while she rides her dragon do you she is
bloodthirsty man she is reveling in the
glory of it all and Jamie he's becoming
nothing short of hopeless he's been
smart he's been in charge and he has
never had to take down an enemy like
this like how is he gonna bounce back
how the hell can Jamie possibly come out
of the situation and feel like him and
Cersei and everyone else has a chance at
actually defeating Daenerys what a great
episode what a fantastic episode this
easily the best season easily easily in
a couple of other moments I wish there
was a little more screen time with Jon
and Theon they reunite the own did some
terrible things because he did save
Sansa from Ramsey John won't kill him it
was such a short-lived moment for
episode that already had so much going
on Ernie you don't really have time to
explore it but I am curious to see if or
how their relationship will develop now
that they are reconnected with each
other there's even some possible
foreshadowing of Jon and Daenerys having
some romance I mean in this episode when
John goes to greet Daenerys Daenerys II
didn't know other way to put it man
speeders gonna be non advertiser
friendly she gives him the [ __ ] I she
gives him the [ __ ]
and when Davos gossiping Davos is making
quips with John about the way John
interacts with Daenerys you know Davis
is picking up I think you're into this
Queen and I think what the way there
will happen in season six Daenerys is
John's aunt at this point it's Game of
Thrones
who cares we've had plenty of incest in
this show let them get together I like
it they're just actors so what'd you
guys think of this episode of Game of
Thrones as it's been your favorite
season so far put it in the condom boxes
yay subscribe to the real rejects flick
that notification bow follow me on that
TV time app and we have a patreon
patreon comm slash the real rejects
plenty of fun exclusive goodies